Here on Earth, radio waves help us communicate
with one another. But in deep space, they
might be able to help us find the Universe’s
missing matter.
Hey guys! Amy with you on DNews today.
There’re a lot of pretty insane things happening
in space all the time, but perhaps none are
so mysterious as fast radio bursts. FRBs are
immensely powerful events that can put out
as much energy as our Sun can in 10,000 years.
But they show up randomly and last just milliseconds,
making them really hard to measure or follow
up on. Scientists have only positively identified
sixteen FRBs in history. And further complicating
our attempts to understand them, FRBs are
rarely if ever observed in real time. For
the most part, they’re discovered months
or even years after they occur by astronomers
combing through archived data.
But trust eager scientists to devise a way
to learn about these mysterious events. In
an attempt to catch an FRB before it’s gone,
a team of international astronomers led by
E. F. Keane set up an early warning system.
If one telescope receives a signal consistent
with an FRB, it alerts other scientists at
other participating observatories so they
can quickly slew their dishes to look in the
area of the sky the signal was first heard.
And it worked! On April 18, 2015, the 64-meter
Parkes Radio Telescope in Australia detected
an FRB flash appropriately named FRB 150418.
The early warning system notified the collaborating
astronomers who got a second telescope in
Australia and a third in Hawaii looking in
the right part of the sky. Visible light imaging
found the FRB came from an elliptical galaxy.
Spectral analysis helped them determine that
galaxy is 6 billion light-years away, an insane
halfway across the visible Universe!
So here’s where it gets interesting. Based
on the energy output of FRBs, astronomers
assumed they were produced when stars formed.
But elliptical galaxies are old and don’t
have a lot of active star formation, and the
event lasted longer than typical stellar formation.
So they concluded that this FRB couldn’t
be the result of the birth of a star.
Instead, it’s more likely that the burst
was caused by a pair of coalescing neutron
stars, the superdense remains of exploded
stars merging together to form a black hole.
This is an incredibly powerful and violent
event that releases a lot of energy in a short
burst that would last milliseconds. This is
consistent with an FRB.
But the story gets even better and has to
do with finding missing matter in the universe.
The total mass/energy makeup of the Universe
can be roughly divided into three components:
dark energy makes up about 70 percent, dark
matter about 25 percent, and normal matter
the remaining 5. The problem is that we only
see half the normal matter; the rest is the
hard to detect gas between galaxies. But this
FRB helped us find that missing matter.
Radio waves traveling through the Universe
are dispersed as they pass through all the
gas and dust distributed through space, and
dispersion depends on what the radio waves
are passing through. So measuring the way
the radio waves from this FRB were altered
as they traveled through space AND knowing
how far they traveled, astronomers can determine
the Universe's makeup, including that missing
matter.
Scientists observed the radio waves produced
from the FRB passed through something that
changed them in a way that was measurable,
and that something turned out to be the missing
matter.
Super neat, eh? Well, some astronomers don’t
think so. A paper has come out since this
initial study saying that Keane’s team may
have jumped the gun on their FRB conclusion.
The rebuttal paper from P. K. G. Williams
and E. Berger looks at the lingering radio
luminosity of the host galaxy and concludes
the signal is consistent with an active galactic
nucleus, not an FRB. Basically that would
mean the location and distance of the observed
event couldn’t be used to measure the composition
of the universe.
So that means we kinda have to come to everyone’s
favourite conclusion: more research is needed!
Sponsorship?
CTA video
But either way, how exactly did astronomers
find these fast radio bursts in the first
place? Laci has some more on these cosmic
phenomena in this
episode right here:
So what do you guys think: Is this a fast
radio burst, an active galactic nucleus, or
aliens? Let us know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe so you never
miss an episode of DNews.